salut il ya quelques jours j'ai eu une
bonne idée enfin je croyais avoir une
bonne idée je me suis dit tiens les
jeudis maintenant dans le mental blog je
fais un nouveau format je vais parler
des trucs qui me passionne des trucs que
j'aime bien et je vais prendre le temps
de les écrire de faire un truc bien
construit vous en ai parlé dimanche sur
la chaîne youtube vous a dit oui
pourquoi pas c'est une belle idée vase
il faut essayer faut voir ce que ça
donne je ne t'en fais dans le plus de
caméras forcément j'ai eu tous ces
commentaires là lundi soir le début de
semaine a été un petit peu speed et là
je me suis dit je fabien a encore eu une
idée brillante parce qu on est jeudi et
que j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller au bout
de ce que je voulais faire j'ai pas eu
le temps d'aller au bout de l'écriture
en fait et je veux pas vous donner un
truc bâclé lâche à peu près dans le même
rythme d'hier il est 15 heures et j'ai
pas encore fait la vidéo enfin si je
suis en train de la faire
oulala ça mon pote c'est de la mise en
abyme je me suis aussi rappelé que vous
avez dit que le jeudi ce sera un peu du
jeu fait comme je veux je vous parle de
ce que j'ai envie tout en restant dans
le mental et je vous parle est un petit
peu plus de moi dans le sens ce qui me
fait rire ce que j'aime ce qui
m'interpelle en fait vraiment donc le
résultat de tout ça c'est que je vais
continuer à écrire la vidéo que je
voulais faire aujourd'hui pour jeudi
prochain et pour aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de deux jeux que j'aime
beaucoup dont un des deux gens que vous
voyez souvent ici pastore est un autre
que vous voyez pas parce qu'il est dans
une autre pièce en fait attention ce
n'est pas du placement de produit on ne
m'a pas offert ces jeux enfin si les
deux hommes les uns ou fermes sont des
amis qu'il nous a offert ça n'a rien à
voir tient ce sont des amis que vous
connaissez d'ailleurs je vous dirai à
chaque fois qu'il m'a offert quoi bon je
commence avec black storica édité par
qui qui gagne mieux une boîte de
chocolats je connais pas à huy à dassa
quand même parce que je connais beaucoup
de boîtes de jeux sérieux vous est pas
précisée ça je suis un joueur j'adore
jouer j'adore tous les jeux d'une
manière générale que ce soit un jeu de
cartes un jeu de plateau un jeu de rôle
je suis joueur dans l'âme en fait je
suis gamer dans l'âme mais pas forcément
sur les jeux électroniques en fait le
jeu électronique
fabien tu à milan on l'avait vu dans tes
poils de barbe est fière qui sont devenu
tout blanc récemment les pointes de bach
sont devenus blancs et boursin que
monsieur rasé aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pas
je suis joueur j'aime jouer et j'aime
avoir des amis joueurs je trouve qu'on
découvre vraiment une personne qu'on
rencontre réellement une personne qu'on
fait un jeu avec elle que ce soit des
amis ou autre c'est toujours chouette de
faire un jeu en fin de soirée d'ailleurs
j'ai relevé un commentaire qui était
super intéressant pour une des astuces
du mercredi le jeu du post-it quelles
astuces pour gagner je vais vous faire
une vidéo là-dessus peut-être même
mercredi prochain tient cette vidéo
devient n'importe quoi parce que je fais
des parenthèses les parenthèses dans les
parenthèses que je ne
jamais reprenons donc sur black story
aux éditions qui gagne c'est jeanne qui
me l'a offert vous savez de jeanne fait
son cinéma
vous venez ça doit être la troisième ou
la quatrième vidéo que j'ai fait cette
année combien aujourd'hui 56 ou alors
c'est un jeu qui se joue à 2 minimum et
à 25 au maximum
en réalité vous jouez à autant que vous
voulez peu importe mais ça peut se faire
à deux et ça peut même se faire et
quelqu'un qui n'a pas envie de jouer ça
c'est cool ça peux juste vous qui jouez
réellement pourquoi parce qu'à
l'intérieur de cette boîte
il ya 50 histoires 50 black story je
vais vous en faire voir une
voilà qui est comme ceci donc il ya un
dessin il ya un titre
et il ya une petite phrase là c'est un
voleur très recherchée se rendit à la
police mais il ne fut pas arrêter pousse
jamais et de l'autre côté de la carte il
ya toute l'histoire en fait qui est
raconté toute l'histoire sur la personne
alors là c'est l'histoire de vidocq en
réalité je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez son histoire mais c'est une
histoire vraie à chaque fois une
histoire lugubre hünnebeck story qui est
nourri de plein de détails de dates
d'explication sur ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi ça s'est passé comment la
personne le faisais et vous allez me
dire comment ça se joue allez-y dix
clubs à deux personnes les rôles sont
clairement définis tu me diras plusieurs
c'est pareil il ya une personne qui va
devenir le maître de l'énigme le maître
des l'énigme prend l'énigme parce que
c'est le maître et prend connaissance de
toute l'histoire qui a derrière c'était
une histoire que la personne va devoir
maîtriser la leur a sous les yeux tout
le long et aux joueurs donc au jour au
singulier ou au pluriel mettre les de
l'énigme va lire l'énoncé qu'il ya ici
un voleur très recherchée se rendit qu'à
la police mais il ne fut pas arrêté plus
jamais il va rajouter la phrase mais
pourquoi donc à partir de ce pourquoi
donc le joueur où les joueurs vont poser
des questions m de l'énigme des
questions auxquelles on peut répondre
uniquement par oui ou par non si c'est
pas le cas le maître de l'énigme fait
reformuler les joueurs vont émettre des
hypothèses il va y avoir un espèce
d'entonnoir tout est possible au départ
il va falloir resserrer les hypothèses
resserré des hypothèses jusqu'à temps de
pouvoir expliquer pourquoi un voleur
très recherchés seront dit à la police
mais il ne fut pas arrêter plus jamais
donc pourquoi ce voleur qui s'est
pourtant rendu à la police ne fut plus
jamais arrêté il ya plein de manières
d'y jouer c'est ça qui est intéressant
plus on est nombreux plus on a une
manière de réfléchir qui est différente
et plus on va attaquer par des angles
différents sur cette énigme là en
particulier on pourrait émettre des
premières hypothèses pour essayer de
chercher pourquoi il s'est rendu à
l'is en fait qu'est ce qui a fait qu'ils
se rendent à la police on pourrait aussi
dans un premier temps cherché à quelle
époque où à quel endroit se sont
déroulés les faits et c'est ça qui est
franchement génial c'est qu'à chaque
fois il ya une phrase qui ne mènent à
rien ça finit par mais pourquoi donc
tout est possible tout est imaginable et
ont créé un rail de réflexion et à la
fin on trouve le pourquoi quand quand
c'est fait le maître de l'énigme nous
donne la carte où l'histoire à tous les
joueurs si on joue ça à plusieurs c'est
super quand tu bois un coup avec du
monde ou même qu'on est plusieurs dans
les transports en commun qu'on s'embête
cc c'est un jeu qui nécessite rien en
fait c'est ça qui est cool après le
maître de lening peut décider que
l'énigme est entre guillemets résolus si
les joueurs ont trouvé de quel crime
célèbre on parlait ou de quel personnage
historique on parle puisque cette
édition là en particulier est basé sur
des faits réels il ya cinquante enigma
différentes il ya la petite règle du jeu
la boîte est très sympathique et
personnellement je me procurais les
autres éditions je vous le conseille
c'est cool
elhorga sa place une des choses
intéressantes avec ce genre de jeu c'est
qu'on peut il jouer à deux c'est quand
même assez rare en fait les jeux en
dehors des jeux vidéo évidemment auquel
on peut jouer à deux et qui sont quand
même intéressant et d'une manière
générale c'est une vraie difficulté de
trouver des jeux à 2 c'est une
difficulté pas pour tout le monde va
pour mon pote js vous souvenez de jean
sébastien massé qui vous a fait un tour
de cartes assez récemment sur ma chaîne
youtube ges aussi c'est un joueur ils
adorent ça il adore jouer l'or aussi sa
compagne sa femme
ils se sont mariés j'étais invité et
m'ont offert un jeu ça s'appelle mr jack
c'est sûr jack l'éventreur vous fait
voir dans mr jack vous avez un plateau
le skip de plateau qu'on connaît bien
dans les jeux de plateau justement avec
des casses en hexagonal qui permettent
des connexions à six cases autour d'elle
et une temporalité défini ça c'est le
nombre de tours qui va y avoir dans le
jeu il va y avoir huit tours au maximum
donc quoi qu'il arrive la partie alors
là il y aurait à peu près similaire
d'une fois à l'autre
alors encore une fois il ya deux
possibilités pour les joueurs il ya
vraiment deux rôles distincts chacun va
choisir un des deux rôles a évidemment
et puis à la partie après on peut
switcher c'est ça qui est intéressant
voici le concept du jeu nous sommes dans
le centre ville de londres et comme vous
pouvez le voir ou pas il fait déjà nuit
et jack l'éventreur a encore frappé et
là je peux vous dire que toute la police
de scotland yard partout s'est mis en
tête d'arrêter jack l'éventreur
ce qu'ils savent pas encore c'est que
jack l'éventreur et parmi eux donc on a
plein de personnages plus ou moins
emblématiques comme le watson l'estrade
où sherlock holmes c et c est bon et
placé sur le plateau en début du jeu
c'est pas aléatoire ça c'est déjà défini
au départ et à chaque tour dans un ordre
défini par les règles et tout est
symbolisée ici il n'y a rien à retenir
alors ça c'est vraiment très pratique
les joueurs vont pouvoir déplacer
certains des jetons certains des
personnages un des deux joueurs c'est
qu'ils aient jack l'éventreur et il doit
faire en sorte que jack puisse soit ne
pas être arrêtée à la fin des huit tours
au lever du soleil soit que jack puisse
s'enfuir du centre ville de londres pour
tous les semer s'échapper l'autre joueur
va représenter les forces de l'ordre et
veut absolument arrêter jack l'éventreur
donc déjà identifié qui est jack l
arrêté l'empêcher de fuir ou l'arrêter
avant le lever du soleil à chaque tour
les joueurs bougent certains personnages
dans un ordre qui est prédéfini
les personnages sont choisis au hasard
avec des cas et chaque personnage a un
pouvoir spécifique par exemple
watson à une lanterne et avec sa
lanterne il peut voir sauf si un
obstacle dans toute la direction de son
faisceau en fait il peut m'éclairer
quelqu'un dans le sombre parce que comme
je voulais dit il fait nuit et effet
nuit d'ailleurs un motif de plus en plus
nuit ça veut dire qu'il est quelle heure
ça veut dire qu'il faut que j'active un
petit peu à la fin de chaque tour sur
les huit tours le joueur qui représente
les forces de l'ordre qui veut arrêter
jack l'éventreur en faire poser la
question suivante à l'autre joueur est
ce que jack est dans la lumière est ce
que jack l'éventreur et éclairé ou non
si il est éclairé le joueur qui veut
sauver jack on veut sauver un criminel
bravo permet de cette carte-là dans
cette position lumineux sinon il va la
mettre dans la position sombre il ya
tout un système de lampadaires qui
s'allument qui s'éteint au fur et à
mesure et si on est sur une case proche
du lampadaire ou si on est éclairé par
la case de watson on est deux fêtes dans
la lumière
alors vous allez me remettre dans ces
cas là c'est très simple on met tout le
monde dans l'ombre pas forcément parce
que comme le choix des personnages à
bouger aléatoire et comme l'ordre des
mouvements par les joueurs est défini à
l'avancé par les règles du jeu alors ce
sera jamais possible de mettre tout le
monde dans la lumière vous demande dans
l'ombre donc les deux joueurs doivent
anticiper à l'avance un peu comme aux
échecs car on va dire c'est des échecs
beaucoup plus
dick est bien plus simplifié mais les
joueurs doivent anticiper les coups sur
ce qui va se passer au final c'est ça
c'est un jeu qui paraît très très simple
dans les règles et en fait qu'ils les
règles sont très simples il n'y a pas
beaucoup de choses à retenir parce que
tout est reporté ici n'y a plus qu'à
suivre le jeu mais toutes les stratégies
qu'on peut élaborer son mortelle surtout
grâce à la temporalité ça fait tic-tac
tic-tac au bout de huit tours la partie
allait terminer donc il faut se bouger
faut tenter des trucs pour réfléchir
assez vite le tour par tour et bien fait
ça s'appelle jack merci geste de me
l'avoir offert je le recommande vraiment
c'est la fin de cette vidéo je ne sais
pas combien de temps je vais filmer je
ne sais pas combien de temps j'ai mis à
la faire j'espère que ces vidéos l'avons
est une respiration un peu dans la
semaine comme ça il y aura les
expériences de mentalisme que je pèse
sur les gens que je rencontre les
petites astuces que jeunes le mercredi
les samedis où c'est un peu plus solide
on va dire avec les master classes et
les dimanches où je vous explique
quelque chose pour bluffer vos proches
je me dis que là on devrait avoir une
chaîne bien fourni le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour vous vous le savez
mais ce que vos amis le savaient ce que
vous êtes abonnés et non abonnés vous à
la chaîne ramener du monde pour les
abonnés aussi à 2500 abonnés c'est
l'objectif un jour rappelle objectif de
1500 on sera tout un échange pour se
parler en même temps pour se connecter
en même temps on va se donner un
rendez-vous
on va pouvoir faire plein de choses
durant deux ou trois heures si cette
vidéo vous a plus pensé à mettre un
pouce en l'air oui mais surtout elle a
partagé pour faire découvrir ce jeu là
d'autres personnes et moi demain je
mentalise ray karim duval
alors rendez vous demain à 17h sur cette
chaîne youtube
ciao
ok